نحن في سوق سته هو السوق الرئيس لمنطقه
تمايو جنوب منطقه الخرطوم
ويتعرض هذا السوق نهار الاربعاء لقصف
مدفعيه ثقيله نتيجه لاستمرار الحرب ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وهذه
المنطقه واحده من الاكثر المناطق المتاثره
وتحديدا هذا السوق الذي يتاثر بشكل كبير
من هذا القصف الذي تسبب في مقتل نحو 17
شخصا
[موسيقى]
وتسبب كذلك في اصابه نحو 106 شخص كما احدث
خسائر في في السوق واحدث كذلك دمارا في
بعض الاماكن التجاريه هذا المكان طبعا من
اكثر الاماكن التي تضررت وكما تشاهدون انه
يعني ناله كثير من الدمار انت كشاهد عيان
ماذا حدث باختصار
ساعتها ونصف
الناس يعني
14 نفر ومدرين اكثر من 17
كثير من الذين يوجدون في هذا السوق
يحاولون يعني
ممارسه حياتهم بشكل طبيعي طبعا نشاهد
تاثيرات هذا القصف
الشظايا المتطايره وتاثيرات هذه الشظايا
على بعض الاماكن التجاريه وهذه الشظ ايا
تحديدا بحسب بحسب شهود العيان انها تسببت
في مقتل اكثر من 10 اشخاص في الحال واصابه
طبعا عشرات من المواطنين الذين كانوا
يتسوقون او الذين كانوا يفترشون الارض
يبيعون بعض الاشياء الصغيره اسامه سيدي
احمد الجزيره من مايو جنوب الخرطوم